we're good to go
all right thank you very much roy uh and
thanks everyone for your time and
welcome to this session on spanner
migration so good afternoon to everyone
in the west coast and the evening if
you're on the east coast and i'm
actually from sydney so it's it's
morning here
i'm neven heinz i'm a senior engineer at
google working on spanner and my focus
is on database migration
so today we're going to
discuss migration to spanner and i'm
going to give an overview
of
um typical steps in a migration
and then we're going to do a deep dive
into some of the core parts of a
migration and then i'm going to describe
best practices and also some migration
tools now just a heads up i think we
advertise this as 30 minutes i probably
have actually about 25 minutes of
material so with questions just sort of
a heads up and an apology in advance
we're probably going to spill a little
bit over the 30 minutes so we might get
to 35 or 40 minutes so apologies in
advance
okay
um so here's a typical set of steps in a
migration and these steps are fairly
independent of the source and target
databases involved and i'm sure for some
of you these steps will be very familiar
what i'm going to do is go over these
steps and highlight them from the
perspective of migrations to spanner and
i'm particularly going to focus on
migrations from my sequel to spanner
most migrations start with some kind of
assessment phase and the goal here is to
determine
if the target database in this case
spanner is likely to be a good fit will
it provide the necessary functionality
will it meet the performance the cost
performance requirements how much work
will the migration be
what are the biggest risks what are the
biggest benefits
the next step
is
often a proof of concept and in many
ways this is sort of an extension of the
assessment so it's typical for a proof
of concept to focus on key items that
come from the assessment like what are
the biggest risks or confirming that the
main benefits of the migration can be
delivered so for example
many spanish users see spanner's ability
to scale as one of its main benefits and
so their pocs often focus on evaluating
spanner's ability to scale for their use
case
the next step step three on this slide
is the core part of the migration
preparation so the design and
implementation of the migration
this can have many components um but
there are three common themes
the first is designing an appropriate
spanner schema the next is determining
how data will be moved from mysql to
spanner
and building components to support this
move and the third is application
changes to switch over to using spanner
this can range from migrating queries to
code changes to switching from my
sequels apis to using spanner's apis and
it could potentially involve application
modernization
the next step step four
is testing and dry runs
now successful migrations involve
significant testing either using test
traffic or parts of your production load
and it's common for these two steps
steps three and steps four to be
intermixed
so you might have an initial design and
an implementation try it out find issues
and then go back and do some redesign
change some implementation
maybe you find a performance issue and
you need to go back and tweak the schema
and for example at an index so this is
really an iterative process between
steps three and four
now many migrations have a target day
for moving data or for completing the
move
and and switching over to using spanner
so this becomes a really critical day a
convergence of all of the planning and
execution phases of a migration
and there's usually a substantial amount
of planning around what happens on this
day with detailed schedules kind of all
hands on deck situation
and a key part of this is knowing how to
respond if things don't go according to
plan
what signals and dashboards should we be
looking at what's the criteria for
reverting how do we revert
now i want to emphasize that all of the
steps i've listed here
you shouldn't take this as too
prescriptive because every migration is
going to be different and which steps
are important which have the biggest
risks which take the most time will vary
significantly from one migration to
another
all right so over the next few slides
i'm going to do a deep dive into each of
these steps
so as we discussed earlier
most migrations start with some kind of
assessment phase
and there's a basic question we want to
answer is spanner a good choice
a common starting point is an analysis
of what mysql features are actually
being used what types and indexes and
queries are used what about stored
procedures stored functions what about
auto increment
and based on this analysis we need to
determine how well these features map
onto spanner so suspana supports most
core types
but not some of the more exotic types
geometry types and point types
that mysql has spanner also doesn't
support stored procedures and the usual
solution there is to pull that
functionality into application code
auto increment and sequences are not
supported in spanner either and these
are challenging to handle at scale
because of the hotspots they can
generate we recommend using random
generation of ids to spread the load
across the key space and there are
several other alternatives um
there are differences between the query
dialect of mysql and spanner so for some
migrations query translation is a really
critical component
now it's worth emphasizing that there's
a huge variation here between different
mysql users
some use
a very broad set of mysql features and
others essentially only use mysql as a
key value store just using very basic
types
now one trend we've observed
for my sequel users who want to migrate
to spanner is that they typically have
very large mysql databases and they're
hitting mysql scalability limits they're
often using sharding and have multiple
mysql replicas as a result they often
limit their use of mysql features that
don't scale well such as stored
procedures triggers auto increment and
they often have very highly optimized
queries especially for their core high
qps operations so this often minimizes
the role of complex queries complex
joins and full table scans
i want to briefly touch on
transaction semantics and locking
so those of you who are familiar with
mysql will know that this is a really
complicated topic
the default my sequel isolation level is
repeatable reads and most my sequel
servers run with this default
this isolation level does indeed provide
repeatable read semantics for standard
sql queries
however the picture gets much more
complicated for dml statements and for
sql queries that acquire locks such
statements are essentially executed
using read committed semantics so it's
not uncommon for mysql users to employ
sophisticated locking strategies to
ensure the transaction semantics they
need or to implement safety checks to
identify and correct anomalies due to
for example lost updates or read or
write skew
now
in contrast
spanner provides a simple robust
transaction model which is
serializability
so all transactions appear if they were
executed in serial order even if some of
the reads and writes of distinct
transactions actually occur in parallel
in other words anomalies like lost
updates fandom reads read sku write sku
and so forth don't happen in spanner
this can significantly simplify code for
managing logs or for
managing my sequel transaction anomalies
now note that transactions do
occasionally fail and a roll back in
spanner and have to be retried so it's
really important
that um your code base and the libraries
you use that together they provide the
appropriate retry logic
okay so
another important aspect of assessment
is looking at how your applications
um communicate with mysql
what drivers do they use do they use
orms are those supported by spanner
finally an assessment usually contains
an analysis of the benefits of using
spanner so what are the key features
that are driving the adoption of spanner
it might be scalability or that spanner
is a fully managed service with no
downtime or it may be just a high
availability of spanner that it provides
four nines up time for original
instances and five nines up time for
multi-reaching configurations
um we'll talk a little more about harbor
bridge later but i want to note here
that
one of the core features of harbour
bridge is that it automatically
generates an assessment report from a
mysql
database all right so moving on to step
two
as we noted before it is
typical for a proof of concept to almost
be an extension of an assessment so the
role of the poc is often to scope out
the biggest risks
validate the main benefits and it's
quite common for a spanner poc to focus
on scalability to establish that spanner
can scale to your needs and workload
given spanner's virtually unbounded
scalability capabilities
demonstrating this is not usually an
issue although
we have seen some cases where hidden
limitations or constraints on the
customer's side can lead to apparent
scalability limits and then it's a
matter of debugging the system end to
end to find out where in the customer
stack the the issue is or in network
configuration and so on
um another aspect of the poc is figuring
out
sizing estimates so how many spanner
nodes will be required for the workload
sizing of any database is workload
dependent and spanner is no exception
we provide some rules of thumb for basic
workloads but we always strongly
recommend that you run tests with your
workload and this is often part of the
poc
implicit in most pocs is learning about
spanner
so it's common for our users to get
valuable spanner experience during the
poc and build their level of comfort and
confidence that spanner will work for
them
a couple of high-level planning aspects
of a poc that are worth mentioning so
it's really important to establish a
clear scope
of the poc don't try to address all
issues and solve all problems but it's
critical to limit the scope to just the
important issues and of course to have a
well-defined and realistic success
criteria for the poc
the next step step three
is the core part of the migration
preparation the design and
implementation of the migration now
there's a lot we could talk about here
but i'm going to focus on three common
tasks schema migration data migration
and application migration and we're
going to talk with talk about schema
migration first
that is what we want to do is design an
efficient span spanner schema to meet
the application and workload needs now
the starting point here is usually types
and columns and tables to support the
application needs
but really critical elements of the
design are around primary keys so these
have to be designed for scalability and
in particular to avoid hot spots
and of course they need to be designed
to be appropriate for the query load so
it's not uncommon for problems to
surface months after a migration that
can be tracked back to issues with
primary key design so this is a really
critical thing to get right
much of schema design is driven by query
performance so the role of secondary
indexes is very critical and spanner
provides some unique capabilities to
optimize queries so for example using
interleaved tables to control the layout
of data between related tables and this
can provide significant query
performance boosts for joins as well as
for writes
inherent in schema design is managing
trade-offs
such as the cost of reads versus the
cost of rights for example
i might add a secondary index to improve
my read performance but this means that
my rights
will become more expensive
so in spanner
a secondary index is implemented as a
spanner table so when i add a secondary
index to a table then any row i add to
that table actually adds two rows it
adds one row to the base table and
another one to the index table so if i
have many secondary indexes then my
rights can become very expensive and
it's really critical to balance these
trade-offs and this is particularly true
if you're moving from mysql where the
balance in costs between indexes
and reads is is a little different so
this is something that coming from a
mysql background pay particular
attention to
the next task we're going to discuss is
data migration and we can have a whole
workshop on data migration so i'm only
going to skim over some really high
level choices here
in short there are many alternatives
but in most cases business needs or
application architecture will quickly
narrow down the choices that you have so
i'm just going to start with the
simplest most basic migration strategy
which is stop and copy so obviously a
big downside here is that you need to
stop your application for a period of
time maybe a few hours or more and the
basic idea is stop everything copy over
all the data from mysql to spanner and
then start up your applications again so
the beauty of this approach is its
simplicity however
most online databases can't be migrated
this way because they can't tolerate the
downtime but if you can seriously
consider doing doing stop and copy all
right the more common approach for my
particularly for my grading online
databases is the so called zero downtime
approach so in this approach
you first take a snapshot of your mysql
database and you start copying it over
the spanner while that's ongoing you
capture all of the real-time changes
using change data capture cdc
and you can either replay them to
spanner while the initial load is
ongoing or you can store the cdc stream
and replay it after the initial load is
complete
there are
some trade-offs involved here
and there are also some important data
consistency issues to get right for
example if the initial load and cdc
rights happen at the same time
you need to ensure that all data from
the initial load doesn't overwrite
incoming new data from cdc
in any case
when the initial snapshot load and cdc
loader complete there is a short period
when you stop the mysql database let the
cdc stream drain to spanner and then
switch over applications to spanner this
switch over time can be a few minutes to
maybe tens of minutes so there's some
downtime but it's typically fairly small
another approach i want to briefly
mention is dual rights
so in this case you modify the
application stack to write to both mysql
and to spanner at the same time
so this also requires an initial load of
data to spanner and some synchronization
between the initial load and the dual
rates to ensure data integrity now the
main benefit of this approach is that
allows you to run both data's both
databases in parallel and to switch from
my sequel to spanner and back again if
needed
however
this can be pretty costly in terms of
resources and there are some other
really difficult technical issues to
resolve and that's around failures so
what happens
if you're committing a transaction
and the transaction succeeds in one
database and fails in the other
how do you recover
i see the question um let me let me
postpone that till the uh until the end
uh and i'll get back to that question
um
another approach is incremental
migration
and this is not a fully general solution
but it can be really useful for some
applications and i've seen this used in
a number of different contexts so the
core starting point is to have a highly
partitioned database so for example
the database might map ids of some kind
to data about those ids and where each
id is independent of other ids so in
particular we need for updates of the
database
to involve just a single id in other
words we don't have any multi-id update
transactions
then what you can do
is you can pick an id
copy its data from mysql over to spanner
and that's usually pretty quick maybe
even you know a few tens of milliseconds
and then from that point on
you serve that id from spanner
and if needed you can actually move this
id back from spanner to mysql now the
core of this approach is an id to
database mapping that has to be
maintained so that you know at all times
um which database actually owns that
particular id
all right the
next step i want to mention in the
design and implementation phase is
application migration and again this is
a really large topic and i'm just going
to touch on a few aspects so
the the first is around application code
changes so what will be needed here is
going to heavily depend
on what drivers the application uses and
whether an orm is used so some database
users
structure their applications
around a database abstraction layer
which is an application specific set of
apis that abstract the core operations
needed from the database
and this can be a huge help for
migration
since it localizes the database specific
code to a small set of apis
so now application migration can now
focus on just rewriting those apis or
the implementation of those apis to use
spanner
at the other extreme
some applications spread their database
code throughout the application and this
can lead to really very time consuming
and complex code migrations
now we briefly mentioned before
that mysql and spanner have
different sql query dialects so each
query used in an application needs to be
checked and potentially rewritten to use
with spanner so sometimes this is fairly
straightforward sometimes it can be a
huge amount of work it depends on the
structure of the application
finally i wanted to briefly mention
stored procedures
these are not supported by spanner
and the usual approach is to rewrite
them as application code
all right
it goes without saying that testing is
fundamental to a successful migration
and this can either use test traffic or
parts of your production load if it is
test traffic
it's really very important to ensure
that the test traffic
realistically models the production
setup and if it's part of your
production load then it's really
important that the part that you use be
representative of your full load
and as i mentioned earlier it's common
for steps three and four to be
intermixed so you might have an initial
design and an implementation try it out
find issues and then go back and do some
redesign and change the implementation
maybe you find performance issues you
need to tweak the schema for example so
this is really an iterative process
all right
now we come to the exciting part
actually doing the migration so first a
quick comment not every migration will
have a migration day so for example if
you use incremental data migration
then your migration is essentially an
incremental continuous process it might
have a start day and an end day but that
could be weeks maybe even months apart
however many migrations do have a target
day for moving or completing day to move
and switching over to using spanner and
this becomes a really critical day
here's where you find out if all of your
planning and testing have been effective
and obviously you really want migration
day to be problem free now one of the
very important aspects of migration day
is knowing what to do if you run into
problems first
how do we know if things are okay or if
there is a problem what signals and
dashboards should we be looking at what
thresholds are acceptable who is the
decision maker for reverting how do we
revert and it's critical that the revert
process has been well tested
so one thing to consider especially for
gaming applications is database warm-up
so for example suppose we're migrating a
game platform from mysql to spanner and
we're going to launch with a new game
so we've gone through all of the tasks
of schema migration and application
migration but we don't actually have any
data because this is a new game so our
tables are empty
now
spanner's load balancing mechanisms
respond to load signals and we'll talk
about this in a little more detail later
but the point is that these mechanisms
take time to respond to load changes and
generally this is not an issue because
they respond fairly quickly on the order
of a few minutes
but if the tables are empty then it can
take several iterations of this load
balancing mechanisms before we can adapt
to the full load of a game launch
so to address this
we need to warm up the tables and
basically this typically done by
pre-populating the tables with synthetic
data and adding load to simulate to
stimulate
spanners load balancing mechanisms and
then the synthetic data can be deleted
now if a database is already populated
with data as part of a data migration
then warm-up is usually not needed
because there's already enough
enough splits and enough warm-up of the
database because of the load of the of
the data
all right
the next couple of slides are going to
address some low-level details of
migrations from specifically from my
sequel to spanner
and i want to first have a look at types
so spanner provides coverage of the core
types of mysql however you'll notice
that where mysql has many different
integer types for example spanner has
just one in 64. so similarly for
floating point numbers
and for charts and text types
there's just one float type in spanner
and there's just one string type
although it's a string type but it has a
parameter with with a length limit
now mysql also has a variety of other
types such as geometry types point line
and so on
spanner doesn't provide a corresponding
type for these and we usually recommend
using either string or bytes here
now let's dig a little bit into the
design of primary keys
and in order to do this i first need to
talk about splits and their role and
then we'll come back and um and talk
about best practices for primary keys so
some of the material here has already
been covered in previous spanner meetups
but i'll briefly recap the idea
so in spanner the primary key space of
each table in a database is partitioned
into chunks called splits so in this
example um the primary key is an integer
and the first split ranges from
minus infinity to minus 100 the next
split from minus 99 to 3 000 and so on
so the same basic thing happens across
other types whether they be strings or
floats and also for multi-column primary
keys
now
each zone in
has a copy of each split so i have a
very simple layout here for a single
region spanner instance where we have
three zone zone a zone b zone c and each
zone has a copy of every split so here's
split zero in zone a he split zero in
zone b and he's split zero in zone c and
they could be distributed somewhat
randomly across the span servers in each
zone
so the key point is that each zone has
full coverage of the key space of a
table and indeed it has a full copy of
the table's data so you can think of
each zone as essentially a standalone
replica and spanner ensures that each
replica stays in sync and has exactly
the same committed data
so what's the role of splits
well there are really two parts to this
the first is that splits are the basis
for distributing table data across fan
servers
and the second is that they form a core
part of an automated sharding mechanism
to balance load across span servers
so splits are not static unlike in many
other databases and
charting shadow databases so in spanner
splits are not static they're
continually on the move and they're
continually evolving so for example if a
split is hot and receiving lots of load
or contains lots of data you'll be split
into smaller splits and if two
neighboring splits have been relatively
inactive for a long time then they'll be
merged so the core ideas behind splits
were actually developed as part of
bigtable many years ago and they've been
adopted and extended to form a core part
of spanner
now
based on our understanding of splits we
can come back to the question you know
what makes a good primary key and very
simply put a good primary key is one
that spreads the key values over the key
space so names are usually a good
primary key unless everyone has the same
name or very similar names
and hashes are also an excellent primary
key
what we want to avoid
is primary keys that clump together
some aspect of the life cycle of
of table rows whether that be creation
of rows or updates and reads or
deletions so for example
auto increment keys are problematic
because with auto increment all new rows
will be in exactly the same part of the
key space um so this will cause a
hotspot for row creation for inserting
into the database
and in fact
with auto increment they'll actually
appear in the same split and it'll be on
the same span server so more generally
we want to design our primary keys to
avoid hotspots
i mentioned several tools for assisting
with migration and i'm going to conclude
with a little more detail of these tools
and their capabilities
i've mentioned harbour bridge several
times so harbourbridge is an open source
tool it's used for various stages of
migration it can be used for assessment
can be used for schema migration for
data migration so here's a sample
workflow
where harbour bridges run and it ingests
data from a mysql or postgres database
and we can either use dump formats like
mysql dump or pg dump or directly
access the database using select queries
and extract schema information using
information schema tables
it builds a spanner schema creates a
database and populates it
with data from the source database and
then it documents that run with a
detailed assessment report that includes
potential issues with type mappings uh
highlights mysql features that aren't
that are used by the source database
that are not supported by spanner and
and also logs any errors encountered so
hubba bridge can also be used to browse
and customize your spanner schema in
what we call schema assistant mode
all right the other two tools i want to
highlight focus on data import
the first is a bulk data import tool
and this is part of our generic google's
generic data flow service which is a
unified streaming and batch processing
service so this service supports
bulk data import into spanner
and supported formats include avro and
csb
and the second tool i want to mention is
a cdc import tool so this is part of our
generic data stream service which is a
change data capture and replication
service
and this service supports my sequel to
spanner cdc
amongst other combinations now let me
stop here and many thanks for your
attention and i'll invite questions and
comments and uh let me
go
over to the
uh
to the chat and i think there was at
least one question there
from andrew all right
all right so andrew asks would you
advocate any small scale migration
testing using the spanner emulator
so actually two questions let me let me
talk about the emulator so um
the the emulator is a really fantastic
piece of technology for testing things
out um and testing out functionality
i would
i would
be
careful though
of
what
um
if you're doing a migration then you're
typically
want to understand
um you know throughput and
performance issues and the emulator is
not going to help you with those so if
you view the emulator as
you know really faithful reproduction of
spanish functionality so for testing
code testing different scenarios but
usually in a migration
as i said you're really interested in
understanding scalability throughput and
performance and the emulator is not
going to be able to help you there so
you know a qualified yes definitely use
the emulator where it's appropriate but
i would not encourage using the emulator
as your only testing environment for
migration testing
um okay how would you handle application
code changes
for transactions that hit the 20k
mutation limit
yeah that's an interesting question um
so
i i guess i i have a question in
response and that is um
um
there is um
there are a number of other tools that
we have for doing large-scale mutations
um and in particular we we have uh ways
of of doing uh partitioned uh dml um now
the petition dml
is typically used when you want to make
a large scale
change uh across the entire database um
and the partition dml allows you to
basically
carve up
the overall operation that you want to
do into
smaller pieces um
and uh and so that way you know we we we
get around the 20k mutation limit
because we're actually splitting up the
operation into multiple uh transactions
now so if you can use it partition dml
is definitely a very convenient tool and
and and will solve the problem you have
the the main um constraints around
partition gml are the um
uh the uh
restrictions on what kinds of
dml operations you can you can use it
for so if you've got something that you
can't use partition dml um then the main
operation or the main approach that's
open to you is to basically split it up
into
smaller sets of mutations so basically
split it up into into smaller
transactions
and that may require some code change or
some manual teasing a part of this large
operation so you know maybe uh andrew do
you have some more background you can
give on the particular use case that you
have
okay
all right uh and andrew also mentions uh
okay no problem um andrew also mentions
the data streaming space there's uh
dibysium
um all right any other questions live
or
anything anyone wants to either ask
about or to uh
give feedback on
yes um eswara asks uh will there be any
sequel rewrite required from my sequel
to spanner uh yeah i mentioned um the
that part of migration from my sequel to
spanner can uh potentially involve
having to rewrite sql queries
spanner and mysql have somewhat
different sql dialects um and so you
know
if you're using very basic sql
constructs
those may well um be uh um
you know fairly easy or or maybe not
require change at all but it's quite
common for mysql applications that uh
use um you know a lot of different
sql constructs
that
requires a lot of
a substantial amount of rewrite um okay
so the follow-up question how much
percentage
how much percentage we need to cover up
on the migration strategy um not quite
sure answer the i'm not quite sure i
follow the question
do you mean
how much of the is the query rewrite of
the migration or are you referring
to migration
uh eswara do you mind clarifying that oh
it's a sql rewrite yes um that depends
tremendously on um
on on the particular application so i
you know i have seen
application migrations where
the sql rewrite was very straightforward
and particular applications that were
organized around a some sort of database
abstraction layer um you know i've heard
a number of uh um spanny users who were
you know very easily able to move from
my sequel over to spano from a query
perspective but i also know customers
who have spent you know a substantial
amount of time on this so you know
it's hard to give an exact percentage
because there's a huge variation across
different customers so i think it's um
you know
some good starting points in estimating
this uh are around well how many
different queries do you have um and and
how many different kinds of queries and
what kinds of features of uh spanner are
those uh sorry what kinds of features of
my sequel are those queries using uh and
then look to see at how the features
that you're using in your my sequel uh
queries you know how those features map
onto onto spanner features so if you're
doing very simple things like you know
standard selects um then you know that
that's going to be very easy to to
migrate over to spanner it may not
require any changes at all if you're
using a lot of
internal mysql operations
so you know built-in functions if you're
using a lot of built-in functions then
you'll need to see how they how they map
over to spanish sometimes their the
syntax is completely identical um
sometimes for built-in functions there
are variations in the naming of the
built-in functions and some built-in
functions of mysql are not supported in
spanner so that's another aspect to look
at so look at the queries that you have
and look at the features um that you're
using uh in in in mysql
all right uh andrew follows up
uh to the other question uh to the early
question i'm mostly
thinking mostly around third-party
applications or orms where one can't as
easily control the size of the
transaction
um
yeah look um
i i agree with you this is this is an
issue um you know when we're more than
happy to work with you on uh you know
finding finding solutions and
understanding more about it we we
recognize that you know this is this is
an issue and something that we're
working on to you know increase the the
limits um you know we don't have any we
don't have any commits we don't have any
any dates we don't have any
announcements on this but you know we're
well aware of the issue so andrew i
definitely strongly encourage you to
interact with the spanner team either
with me or other people in the in the
spanner team um or with your point of
contact on the sales side we'd love to
hear more about the problems uh that
that that you're having and i completely
agree when you're using a third-party
tool or an orm you often don't have the
control um over this um so yeah please
please get in touch with us and i think
it'll depend on the specifics of the of
the problem that you have
all right uh any other questions
thank you eswara and andrew
all right well thank you everybody for
attending and
i think
there are no other questions
we will wrap it up
thanks and thanks roy for hosting
absolutely thank you nevin and thank you
everyone for joining um i will end the
recording right now thank you all